PRESIDENT THAT WERE ALL WRONG.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF THE
TONIGHT'S "ANGLE."
BEFORE WE GET TO OUR MAIN TOPIC,
IT'S A NEW YEAR.
ARE EVERYWHERE.
THEY ARE BLOOMING.
IT'S LIKE SPRING TIME.
IT'S SO COLDOUD.
REMEMBER A YEAR AGO WHEN THE
LIBERAL PROPHETS OF DOOM
PREDICTED THAT A TRUMP
AMERICA'S RETREAT FROM THE
WORLD.
BOY, WERE THEY WRONG.
A YEAR LATER EVEN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" IS GRUDGINGLY ADMITTING
DUE TO TRUMP'S ROLLBACK,
BUSINESS LEADERS ARE AWASH IN A
WAVE OF OPTIMISM INVESTING IN
NEW PLANTS, EQUIPMENT AND
FACTORY UPGRADES THAT BOLSTER
ECONOMIC GOTH.
-- GROWTH.
FORECASTERS ARE GOING UPWARD
REPORTED THAT WAGES ARE RISING
DO YOU BELIEVE THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IN AREAS WITH LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT.
PAYCHECKS ARE STARTING TO SWELL.
HERE'S MY PREDIC.
AS TRUMP'S POLICY AND TAX CUTS
NOW TO THE LATEST SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OPPORTUNISM OUT OF
HOLLYWOOD.
THEY GOT STAR TREATMENT IN
MAGAZINES AND NEWSPAPERS.
A COUPLE OF 300 FEMALE POWER
AN EFFORT TO FIGHT SEXUAL
THE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY
ITSELF.
IT'S CONVENIENT THAT THESE
POWERFUL WOMEN THAT KNEW ABOUT
HARVEY WEINSTEIN AND OTHERS LIKE
HIM ARE SEEKING TO CLEANSE
THEMSELVES FROM ANY GUILT BY
SOCIAL MEDIA CORRESPONDENT TO
THIS TYPE OF GESTURE.
BEHEATH THE GIRL POWER
PLATITUDES AND RECRUITING ANITA
HILL TO WRITE UP A BLUEPRINT TO
END SEXUAL HARASSMENT, THIS
FEELS LIKE ANOTHER LEFTIST HACK
GROUP.
LIKE A POLITICAL ACTION
COMMITTEE.
AT THE HEART IS A LEGAL DEFENSE
FUND WITH A $13 MILLION WAR
CHEST THAT WILL BE USED TO
LITIGATE SEXUAL HARASSMENT
CLAIMS.
DONORS?
TO FUND THIS.
CHEST.
HER ONLY PREVIOUS GAME TO FAME
SHE WAS CHIEF OF STAFF TO
MICHELLE OBAMA.
THE WHOLE EFFORT IS BEING
OVERSEEN BY THE NATIONAL WOMEN'S
LAW CENTERS LEGAL NETWORK FOR
THIS LEGAL NETWORK WAS JUST
CREATED LAST OCTOBER ACCORDING
TO THE SEE.
IN RESPONSE TO THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY'S ALL OUT ASSAULT ON
WOMEN'S RIGHTS.
LET'S BE CLEAR WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT.
THIS IS NOT AN EFFORT TO PROTECT
WOMEN ALTHOUGH THE TRAPPINGS ARE
THERE.
THERE IS AN OBVIOUS ATTEMPT BY
HOLLYWOOD LEFTISTS TO ORGANIZE
FOR 2018 AND 2020.
TIMES UP MEMBERS INCLUDE
EVALONGERIAR AND OTHERS THAT
SHOULD A HILARIOUS CHALLENGE.
AT THE GOLDEN GLOBES ON SUNDAY,
WOMEN ARE BEING ASKED TO SWEAR
BLACK IS CLASSIC, BUT IT'S KIND
OF DEPRESSING.
THEIR ENTIRE BOX OFFICE WAS
>> WOMEN ARE EXPECTED TO LOOK
BEAUTIFUL AND SMILE AND NOT SAY
MUCH.
LONGERIA SAID WE ARE NOT WILLING
TO JUST BE ORNAMENTS AND CELL
THIS AWARDS SHOW WITHOUT ASKING
BIG QUESTIONS ABOUT POWER IN
HOLLYWOOD.
>> Laura: MAYBE THIS IS AN
ATTEMPT TO BRING UP THE GOLDEN
GLOBE SAGGING RATINGS.
MANY OF THESE WOMEN MADE MILLION
DOLLARS FLAUNTING THEIR BODIES.
IN THE AWARDS SHOWS, THERE ARE
TALENTED PEOPLE THERE, WOMEN AND
MEN.
BUT AT TIMES THE DRESSES DEFY
THE LAWS OF PHYSICS WITH DOUBLE
SIDED TAPE.
YOU CAN WEAR WHATEVER YOU WANT,
IT IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
OBJECTIFIED WOMEN.
THEY ARE THE MORAL CONSCIENCE OF
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY?
ARE THEY LOOKING LIKE PILGRIMS?
PERHAPS A LITTLE HOUSE ON THE
PRAIRIE COLLECTION WILL MAKE A
PREMIER ON THE GOLDEN GLOBES.
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
YOU KNOW WHO WILL DO MORE TO
HELP WOMEN, THEY WON'T ADMIT IT,
BUT I TELL YOU WHO.
ALL WOMEN.
WOMEN ARE HALF THE WORK FORCE IF
WAGES GOING UP AND OPTIMISM AND
CONFIDENCE.
IF THEY REALLY CARED THERE THEIR